[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of ceos
founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
can you hear me in a second
thank you so much that made me feel sick
[Music]
hello
gary
hi hi
it's tic-tac thursday
i am super excited for this one this i
think will bring a lot of value to a lot
of people um obviously i've been on this
game since it was called musically here
in the united states and so it'll be
very exciting to see
what uh what these incredible leaders in
marketing have to say and it's great to
see everybody shirley wu ryan terry zen
rasta morgan here on linkedin liz on
uh linkedin simon on youtube thank you
for joining us at marketing for now
andrea how was your uh how was your uh
new years how's your first
month of 2022 how are you it's been it's
been awesome i feel really lucky my my
family's healthy
um and we're launching things like crazy
as you know gary so it's uh it's been
it's been a great ride yeah let's get
into it i know we started hair loss yeah
we're gonna go deep today we got a
two-hour session we're gonna kick things
off with chris brant we're bringing him
back again chris is chief marketing
officer of tick tock doing some really
cool st at tic toc
chief marketing officer at chipotle
doing some great stuff on on tick tock
we're so happy to have you back chris
oh thanks for having me back i don't
know whether that's i did a bad job the
first time and so i'm getting a redo or
i don't know
no no self-deprecation here from good
work chris chris get right into it um
for everybody listening because we've
only got seven minutes here so let's
pack it in
for everybody listening how is chipotle
such an
at
under your helm has been so good at
contemporary marketing truly one of the
few brands that i watch from a farm like
that crew over there gets it um
have you been thinking about it and
what's kind of like on your mind
yeah well thank you for saying that i
think that um you know all credit to the
team we've really assembled an amazing
team and i think that you know we we set
out in 2018 when most of us started at
chipotle to be
more visible more relevant and more
loved and a big part of that was being
on social and uh you know and i think
that we just wanted to make sure we were
doing the right things um and the right
way and wherever we appear and i think
that you need to appear
you know people call it omnichannel we
used to call it 360 degree marketing
whatever wherever you need wherever you
are you have to appear there the right
way and i think that that's the big part
your creative can't be the same on
snapchat as on tick tock as it is on tv
as it is anywhere else and the team just
does a fabulous job of figuring out the
other about figuring out where the
intersection of culture and chipotle
lives because we can't jump on every
trend we shouldn't jump on every trend
some of them don't fit us yes but in the
case of tick tock i mean we jumped on
that we we were talking about tick tock
as a place that our consumers are back
at the end of 2018
but we didn't have a good idea to go on
tick tock in a really real quick and
real quick i'm sorry to interrupt i i'm
i'm vibing with all this this is an
insight for a lot of marketers watch
this show so i want to help them and i
actually want to get the insight here
ideas are everything and then the
execution is everything right
a brand
and i couldn't agree with you more your
constituents are were on there from day
one and again i think the accolades i
gave you is because i do think you're
moving faster and more native
than a lot of your contemporaries in
fortune 5000 marketing world
but one thing you just said did catch my
attention
does it run through your mind or the
brand's team's mind
the teammates the agency partners that
you don't necessarily when a platform is
that meaningful need a core idea like a
campaign you just need to actually be in
the game
that you know
is there ever a debate of like okay yeah
we don't have our idea yet
but let's actually make content from
having a day-to-day pulse versus a core
idea or did you or do you normally
or or always or sometimes feel no i want
to go in with an id and then we'll start
figuring out the day to day after
because i think it's an interesting
nuance that i'm very curious what your
take on that is i think there's some of
both the one thing we don't want to be
is lame when we first go on a platform
though we don't want to go in we don't
want to go in with something that
doesn't feel maybe
but you agree you agree i think because
i'm watching from afar again you agree
that
doing a challenge or doing something
that's campaign oriented
you could equally not be lame by just
doing an actual good tick tock right out
the gate that you guys know what the
[ __ ] is going on that you could yes and
so but i think that when you're looking
to make a bigger splash we for example
we when we were talking to them at the
end of 2018 we didn't do anything until
the beginning of 2019 because we didn't
feel like we wanted to do a tick tock
challenge brands weren't doing them at
the time and we felt like what is our
tick tock challenge that will really
make a splash well we didn't know so we
didn't do anything and we were waiting
and waiting and then we then we we had
one of our actually one of our team
members in a restaurant had this cool
way he could flip the lid up on to a
bowl
and we posted it on instagram first and
it got a million views like that we're
like hey this could be it so yeah
we got an influencer who loved chipotle
was absolutely in love with japo i think
that's the other part is use influencers
who are absolutely in love with your
brand even if they're not the biggest
influencer because you'll get content
that just feels so much more organic and
genuine and i think that that we
launched that and we got you know at 250
million views which was a lot of views
you know back in 2019 we got that right
away and so we were off to the races but
i think whether it's tick tock or
whether it was snapchat or instagram or
whatever i think you want to take a step
back too and understand what that
platform is about
and for the consumer and so instagram's
about inspiration tick tock happens to
be about mood lifting an awareness
generator it's almost like tv for gen z
so
kind of behave like that but have
content that looks like it's created by
it looks like it's ugc
because if you don't
you just
you know you finished you're gonna
you're gonna be terrible you're gonna be
the old guy at a hot club exactly right
hundred percent chris
have you you know you're so busy
is there i know we're talking tic tac
but i'm gonna get value out of you is
there any social network that you
actually consume as a human being
without a marketing
mind that lends on or are you just kind
of too busy and there's too much going
on i watch a lot of tick tock as a
consumer to be honest i think because
because
because the interest graph right because
it is you're seeing things i think the
algorithm is really good um if mine
looks very different from my wife's but
the number the the the creativity and
the humor that people have
amazes me on tick tock and the talent
and so i that's that's the one it is an
it is a black hole you can get on there
and all of a sudden 20 minutes have gone
by and you're like oh what just happened
but i've you know i've picked up picked
up a lot of golf tips um but i've also
just it's funny it's funny i invested in
so i talk a lot about like i invested in
facebook and twitter and i always
mentioned that i invested in tumblr at
the time and i remember the reason i
invested in tumblr
in 2008 or nine or seven um was
because
they were building a social
they were building an interest graph
social network not a
social graph and i remember being
interested in that that people were
following not like people but like the
kind of art they liked and things of
that nature and i was very fascinated
and always felt that the interest graph
that's why i fell in love with early
facebook you know algorithm because fan
pages could go viral that kind of
changed over time and i think tick tock
has really grabbed on to that yeah i i
agree and then and i think that the
outlet for creativity is is amazing
chris thanks for having me
thanks for having me appreciate it
by the way real quick andrea i'm sorry
uh dan masso gary v king of interrupting
wow i apologize it's only 10 minutes
with these incredible individuals and i
feel like when the essence of what
they're trying to say is accomplished to
many of you i try to get one or two more
nuggets out of you it is not because i'm
trying to be rude i'm excited and i want
to squeeze as much in and i'm making a
subjective call on the fly that the
point was made and i'm hoping that uh
that uh
lands
on to the next one
next up we welcome kalyn thornton he's
the cmo of gatorade he joined in 2021
after 10 years at doing transformational
things at nike and jordan brand and his
first sport
gymnastics welcome kailyn oh you're just
gonna put it out there from the top okay
i'm gonna get
i might be i might be uh i might be a
little bit more careful with my
interrupting with you my man you are a
professional football player and a beast
i'm also i'm also incredibly fond of you
it's been nice getting to know you this
is obviously one of the iconic brands
obviously so many uh that are on tick
tock touch this brand love this brand
interactive brand so let's this i
actually don't know so let's go there
what is uh what is the journey been kt
for gatorade you know obviously you're
in this realm fairly recently so there
was things obviously happening before
you
now you're here what what's the kind of
quote-unquote 4-1-1 no absolutely one uh
echo the sentiment been a pleasure to
get to know you and honored to be here
so it's such an illustrious panel of
speakers
for me uh you're right i got i joined
last march um i'm coming up on a year
and i'm still learning a ton yeah i will
qualify that but really for for gatorade
we've talked a lot about over the past
year just this notion such an historic
brand 50 years of heritage backed by
science
a massive sports fuel company but we
need to shift more to fueling sport
culture has been the conversation and so
getting into the topic today when you
think about a opportunity like tick tock
and and what we've leaned into it is
that intersection of sports and culture
it is that intersection of creativity
that there's there's just a ton of
opportunity for us to take all that dna
and heritage and the athletes we work
with and the conversation um that we'd
like to have and bring that into the
language and experience that this next
generation is seeking so that's really
the future that's kind of what we're
trying that's what we're building
towards
what um what excites you about tick tock
i love the notion you were alluding to
it in the last conversation with chris
going from the social graph to interest
graph is a big part of it um and that's
especially critical for us as we start
to think about different sports in
different ways in which
consumers athletes define themselves as
uh define themselves as an athlete or
the sport so we need to learn more about
some of the emerging sports uh so that's
one piece the other piece that's really
really exciting for me is this notion of
rather than having this two-way
conversation that social
uh introduced now we're in a co-creation
mode so now we can actually unlock and
unleash some of our most loyal consumers
and athletes and fans to extend
themselves
and really drive another voice for the
brand that quite honestly we ourselves
can't do on our own so being in being in
a partnership with these creators really
understanding what are the types of
conversations and creative they want to
see from us and spaces we want to play
in is also the unlock for us and what's
super exciting
how would you grade the brand on tick
tock right now you know obviously it's a
that's a tough question grading your own
homework you have a partners and
internal people but i think it's
important for people to see like how
leaders analyze their stuff like hey at
the time of that marketing helm for this
iconic brand you feeling good where
you're at you know you're
you are a professional athlete you were
like i'm sure you you have that means
there's competitiveness there's there's
holding yourself to a standard like do
you guys think you're you're killing it
do you got are you are you worried do
you think you're
you're focused on some macro work so
you're just not getting to it given you
know how big brands sometimes
you know i mean you've gotten to know me
i think big brands
i think big brands underestimate the
emerging and over fantasize of the past
like what
how do you grade gatorade on on the talk
right now no it's a great question i
think about it and i'll go back to the
athlete analogy as an athlete one thing
that we're always doing is working on
our craft and you're at different stages
of your development and your training at
the different stages in life and and for
for us as a brand gatorade is very much
so we're still we're at the beginning
stages we just picked up the weights
we're just running our first few sprints
out on the field um and so we're trying
to establish our foundation and really
learn from the platform as we build and
potentially get to a place where we are
setting the standard across not only our
space but across the industry so i'd say
very much so we're at the beginning i
wouldn't give us a grade because i think
we're doing amazing at what our training
goals are for today so our training
goals are for today become more familiar
with the platform understand the tools
and we've we've learned a ton a lot of
the conversation that we're just having
how to show up an authentic way how to
make sure
that we are
leveraging the creative economy and
creative lens are you thinking a lot
about that like hey look at that dope
video that got four million views with
that kid that used gatorade for it
should we team up with with kid over
there is that some of the stuff going
through your head absolutely that and
even like one of the things you actually
actually i'm sorry interrupt everyone uh
do you recommend for a lot of people
listening here who are creators
that love brands
to
just naturally do it because i know a
lot of creators tell me i love this
brand but i'm gonna make them pay
they're gonna if they're gonna get
something for me i'm gonna wait to get
paid i'm like no no make something
awesome with that kitkat bar
and then then kitkat will come back and
come like do you think it's actually a
smart strategic move for some people
here that are wildly creative to just
integrate big brands into their content
with the knowledge that if a couple of
them hit they're going to be getting a
phone call from that brand and saying yo
let's dance
yeah i mean first and foremost even back
to what chris was saying whether you're
on the brand side or the creator side do
what's most authentic to you and what
you're passionate about so if you love
gatorade then the question around
whether or not you should get paid
almost shouldn't even be a question if
you represent because we're looking for
it and ultimately uh at least in our
case we're going to take care of it and
that was really what was at the heart of
what was successful for us in tick tock
in our social squad
we reached out to the community and
basically asked who wanted to start this
relationship with the brand who felt
like they could speak to it
authentically and and i think is an
exact example of what you're saying
where it wasn't as much around
transaction it was setting up a
relationship on how we wanted to partner
with these creators uh in order to in
order to speak authentically on the
platform
quick little left turn
what's your recommendation
for people that are looking to pivot in
their career
right
because you surely did that
um
or the youngsters here who want to be i
mean there's a lot people freaking out
about your about your hoodie
right it you know gatorade is a super
popular brand you're the cmo the chief
marketing officer what about two minutes
of advice for the kids or the 45 year
old kids and what i mean by that in a
good way is that youthful energy of like
i can still change my you know i've been
a lawyer but i'm going to be the cmo of
gatorade one day what's a good way to in
your opinion get into the marketing
field and get to the highest levels like
you have
um one i'm incredibly humbled if you
would have told my younger self that i
would be in this position today to be
cmo of gatorade to have an amazing
career at nike and jordan and
all do that after playing in a couple
years professionally for the cowboys i
would not have believed you i'd been
like i was trying to keep the cowboys
part out because i know it's salty in
dallas right now okay it is salty out
there you know i rap strong you know
wrong
um but to answer your question like
honestly the best advice i ever got was
chase the learning chase the experiences
like
figure out what it is that you that you
want to have in terms of your own
development and don't worry about the
role or the title or or the job like
that that will come if you have enough
intellectual curiosity and i think as
i've gotten older one of the things
that's that's similar advice that a lot
of mentors give but i think the other
thing i've i've appreciated now is like
what do you actually also have to
unlearn especially when you're getting
into these new spaces where
it might challenge the status quo of
what you may have picked up along the
way and such a fine balance and it also
requires you to be completely self-aware
understand where you might have your own
biases or philosophical philosophical
differences but i think that notion of
being curious and electric
learning is big before i let you sleek
out sure biggest thing biggest
thing you've learned in the last
call it 36 months
that changed your perspective on a
belief you had about marketing
anything
i think
i don't know if it changed my
perspective on marketing because i
always knew change was a part of
marketing you always have to be up to
speed i don't think i quite
fully appreciated how marketing and
brands are going to fundamentally shift
business
drivers moving forward until i started
understanding where the intersection of
a company like gatorade and what we do
also well with supply chain is
now meeting up with this digital
frontier and so we're talking a lot
about marketing through the lens of tick
tock today but i think you're going to
see a lot more platforms i know you're
an expert in all things metaverse and
nfts i think that is fundamentally going
to change the way we even define
ourselves as marketers
marketing as a profit center yep yep yep
great to see you my friend you too thank
y'all for having me
thank you kailyn
gary next we're going to welcome jeremy
padauer he's the chief brand officer at
jazz wares
you know squish mellows pokemon
it's it's pretty crazy all the things
that i've been learning from jeremy what
i didn't know is that jeremy sold his
company wicked cool toys and i'm hoping
you're gonna get into that a little bit
um he's now recognized as uh one of the
biggest faces in the business of play
he's an entrepreneur toy industry
executive and a badass collector among
many things
jeremy
thank you so much
jeremy i mean look you you know this i
mean when anybody who has a backdrop
that is similar to the one i have in my
office is always going to be somebody i
love it's been a fun interacting with
you through the years brother nice to
finally do something together um why
don't you tell everybody a little bit
about jazwares first because i think
some may not know it as much they know
the brands that are associated but when
we talk about that for two seconds and
then we'll go into the tick tock
question
yeah well first of all thank you for
having me today i feel like i'm
representing the toy industry
so jazz wares is the sixth largest toy
company and we have been blowing up uh
jasper's about is 25 years old this year
founded by a guy named judd zuberski
who's a genius in our space
and through acquisition as she mentioned
wicked cool toys and a lot of organic
growth focusing on brands like global uh
partner for pokemon roblox fortnite we
own squishmallows
uh um my goodness coco melon which is a
brand that we found a few years ago when
we focused on the social space i mean
jazwares has competed by focusing on
areas that other people are not
participating and frankly speaking
everything in the toy industry is very
much like fashion it's trend based so we
constantly are looking at change we're
constantly looking at pivoting to make
sure that we capture what's the latest
opportunities in the space and look even
in your world i mean the the nft
universe is part of that uh we've been
at the very forefront of that on the
individual level as collectors but also
trying to identify how to extend that as
a larger business opportunity especially
in the world where things are so
decentralized and individual holders of
nfts can compete with the larger brand
organization so we are
dealing with all of that right now but
the biggest i would say the thing that
jazwares does better than anyone else is
that we don't just look for brands we
participate we invest we individually go
after opportunities and just pour
ourselves into it
i love it
talk to me about tick tock
considering that you guys and gals are
in the business of trends
uh and just obviously me spending a lot
of time in that universe you know one
even for squish me which has been just
such a monster hit i don't think people
you know anybody that knows in the
comments if you know what's going on
with squish leave it so everybody else
can see what's going on because if
you're in it you know um was tick tock a
big factor in that explosion was it not
um what are you seeing in tick tock
well you know collecting and community
go hand in hand and it's it's just like
you cannot break that bond if you don't
have a community you don't have a
collection it's not just about secondary
market value it's about who you have
shared experiences with
and squishmallows is quite possibly one
of the greatest examples of collecting
by community
squishmallows originally was launched in
2017. it was a company called kelly toy
guy named jonathan kelly and when it was
launched it was literally another one of
these just toy brands that was going to
try it at walgreens to see what happened
but this special huggable
phenomenally identifiable character
um which was the original squish squad
squishmallows character of eight blew
out within 24 hours with no marketing
wow
and immediately what was identified was
you know what this is exactly the type
of brand that if we seed it with enough
youtubers and enough uh at the time
youtube instagramers that something
might happen and it absolutely did sent
it out to about 100 youtubers sent out
the entire squad and then what happened
was in 2018-19
there was a migration from the
investment in facebook and instagram
into tick tock by the influencers
themselves identifying that that was
going to be the next big medium and
we've had over four billion organic
integrations with tick tock so what
we've learned is it's been it's been as
much about learning when not to spend
money on marketing yes let the community
drive
as it has to been to spend money on
marketing which is
spending about look spending on
marketing is always right when you spend
good money
when when something's happening
organically there's nothing better
there's nothing better than when you
make a hoodie
and four famous people just find it in a
shop you haven't spent a dollar on
anything you didn't have enough money to
give samples to influencers and they
love because they love it and they wear
it and they post on instagram and your
business takes off like like nothing
there is not a pe you could spend the
best penny
i've been very proud of how good i am at
spending money on marketing because i'm
always at the thing when it's
underpriced yes the best penny i ever
spent on marketing for myself or my dad
is not better than organic
yes absolutely and and that has been
again our lesson is that if we support
the communities and we and we love we
love the communities we integrate
ourselves to the communities
that they drive the messaging and and so
while we are harnessing the power of
that we're not directing it we're
allowing and and making sure that we
clearly communicate that this is you
know this is theirs and we're simply
fostering and and ebbing and flowing
with that and frankly speaking you know
the way you run your business and
looking at things like v friends it's a
very similar philosophy
what did you when did you get tick-tock
personally just your own journey you're
busy you got a lot going on like when
did it really and what was it that made
you go okay
you know okay this is not a this isn't
thirteen-year-old just dancing there's
something going on here yeah i i think i
think charlie dimiglio uh dancing was
the original uh what tick tock is big
wow she's got 20 million followers now
50 now 100.
and but you start flipping and it the
algorithm kind of figures you out and it
says hey maybe you don't want to see
dancing kids maybe what you're
interested in is cooking and what you're
interested in is collectibles and what
you're interested in and it figures you
out it is one of the smartest engines
i've ever seen
it's brilliant because it it knows you
it knows your interests and it delivers
it to you and it's just day after day
after day
that that information
simple very simple so for for me what i
recognize as a marketer
is that it is the best dollar spent
because if the algorithm is that smart
and it knows the consumer that well then
it's able to extend mentally what's the
next thing they may be interested in
participating in and if it's
collectibles goodness we know how to
deliver those
um what was the first collectible just
for fun now a couple of minutes left
first collectible that you entered your
life
so my brother's 13 years older than me
and uh
i'm 11 years older than aj
oh and so many of the questions that
i've heard aj asked about sports or
collecting or business always start with
well my brother gary's 11 years older
than me so that was a really funny
moment for me
yeah well i've i had that same i went to
kindergarten the same day he went to
college but he made an indelible mark on
my life and when i was three years old
he took me to a flea market
and uh he bought me uh a penny that was
97 years old and we communicated about
when i was 6 years old this was going to
be 100 years old and i will tell you
that my entire life was shaped on that
moment in terms of collecting like i am
a collector for life
um i and and it's not just about the
item it's it's what goes with the story
the story
it's always the story i was trying to
make i was doing props and drops where i
was talking about why i thought 2014
name coin bitcoin and very early
ethereum 17 18 19 projects how they were
going to play out differently in 50
years than all the projects that are
dropping now yeah and i in real time was
doing the show and went on ebay and
pulled up that somebody sold yesterday
a valentine's day card just a
valentine's day card from 1907 for 15
for 15
and the point i was trying to make is
humans will always collect and there
will always always always even if
there's not a ton of demand if you go
old enough it's going to just play out
as meaning something
and that the fact that this whole world
is coming and it will evolve and
there'll be you know i i talk a lot
about thinking a lot of things will
collapse
there's so much going on in nfts that
are similar to beanie babies people are
only buying for the sake of this flip
means they're not falling in love with
the characters right the community
part's not there the commerce part is so
you know one of the reasons i think 98
to 99 are gonna fail is they have the
beanie baby thing they can be hot for
three or four months or a year even but
and but nonetheless
um i totally understand the shaping of
collectibility and the fun grown-ups
having fun grown-ups having fun
with
this stuff collecting is the trend of
the last five years that people are
missing it that there's a joy factor
a relationship factor of collecting
cards i think vhs tapes why you used to
watch movie like you could see the whole
thing happening no germ
absolutely tickets vhs all of that you
could see it happening in real time love
you buddy thanks for being on the show
we'll talk soon okay
andrew thanks for having me on i know
you guys have a killer lineup want to
give some people the preview because i
know some people occasionally bounce off
when i when i leave but like the
lineup's insane oh yeah it's it's
incredible so next up we've got um the
nfl uh and we've got emily zuge who's
going to be joining in on that
conversation we've got the cmo from eos
um and a creator that they've done a lot
of collaborations with carly joy
we've got a whole bunch of creators so
spencer x the four old gays michael lee
um and then we're bringing sophie
jameson back the chief tick-tock officer
from nerf we want to hear what's up in
her world as it continues to change so
don't leave anybody bye everyone
you go gary
all right take it easy
so next up we're going gonna welcome
vayner media's peter chun to the virtual
stage hey peter how's it going in
california
looks like it's a little sunny out there
yeah hey andrea this is um yeah very
fortunate to be out here given the
weather and the circumstances on the
east coast so yeah fantastic well super
fired up to uh for to have our next
guest join us
it is none other other than ian
trumbetta he's svp of social influencer
and content marketing at the nfl
uh ian has done a masterful job if i can
say in really helping to transform a
more modern approach at the nfl he's
going to give us some some tips and
tricks on that
he oversees the integration of all
things social and content for not only
the league but players and all of the
club handles so lots there and has put a
particular focus on gen z and youth
audiences
so i will leave it to the two of you to
get started thanks so much for joining
thank you thanks andrea
hey great to see you again yeah so
excited for this man
um all right so
so one of the things we discussed and
and gary alluded to this in some of the
earlier sessions is you know you are in
a position where there's so much growth
and impact that you've had just not only
in the tick tock platform to consumers
but also to advertisers and in the
spirit of trying to deliver some value i
think we're going to have really good
conversations and nuggets for those that
are on the brand side that are looking
to lean in
so i actually would love to start with
your origin story so talk a little bit
about your background
and i think it's really important
because people will assume because you
have the nfl logo
that you'll just be successful on the
platform and it's actually the opposite
it's probably harder and i think a lot
of this comes from your background your
dna so i think it'd be super helpful to
provide people a little bit of that
context
yeah awesome thanks peter and i first of
all just want to shout out all of you at
vayner you guys do such an awesome job
building this community and putting
events like this on so i just wanted to
tell you how humbled i am to be a part
of it and thank you guys for having me
on
um as a as it relates back to my origin
story um i i was very fortunate i
started as an unpaid intern at shy day
uh in the late 90s and early 2000s and
was fortunate to get a job there but uh
that was a place that was really magical
at the time i mean you had apple there
with steve jobs and launching itunes and
the mac and so on um in addition to that
you had taco bell and the ioc so just a
very diverse slate of brands that were
doing incredible world-class work uh so
that was a really
foundational time for me to be there uh
and learn from some of the best like lee
clow and he would spend time with us as
young account people and and teach us
about what he was thinking about from a
creative strategy perspective and so on
um as the years went on there i had a
great run at shyat um there was a brand
this quirky
uh austrian brand called red bull that
was popping up all over the city
it was very mysterious and weird i mean
it was it was in the clubs and
you'd see the sampling cars around you
started seeing these kind of these
grassroots events popping up
and my friends and i were really taking
note of it and uh one of my buddies from
cheyenne actually went to go work for
red bull and
he kept telling me for months so you've
got you've got to come over here there
we're rewriting the playbook for
marketing and the space and inventing a
new category this energy drink category
uh so i declined initially but after
about six months of seeing what was
going on uh i took the flyer and
actually went over to work together with
with red bull and help out with their
advertising and marketing and at that
time i think there was about 30 people
in the north american headquarters just
to give you a sense of how how small it
was at that time
and it was just a tremendous experience
learning about grassroots grassroots
events on-premise marketing
understanding really how to do athlete
marketing in some of these niche sports
at scale just a tremendous opportunity
so while we were there i had a couple
different stints um gaming became a
vertical uh gaming became a vertical for
us and
activision was one of the partners we
were working with and
a fast forward in 2014 uh they offered
me a role and that role was to work
across titles in a variety of different
ways and was fortunate to to learn all
about you know launching titles and
through our cmo tim ellis this idea of
big entertainment marketing
tied to always-on engagement that was a
really big part of how we marketed those
games
and then when tim
took the job at the nfl as a cmo
you know he
offered me a great position and i'm a
huge sports fan i mean i'm as big of a
steelers fan as probably gary is a jets
fan and and uh when the opportunity came
over for
for me to to help out and really look at
what we're doing from a youth
perspective what we're doing from a gen
z
perspective across social influencer i
had to jump at the chance so for the
last three years i've been here at the
nfl overseeing social influencer and
content marketing and it's just been
it's been terrific
yeah so so really i mean red bull in its
day today is such a commonplace brand
but in its heyday when it was ramping up
it was an unknown brand it was very
grassroot with culture and community um
so really you've been at the forefront
of really being part of companies that
have been disruptors in the space
obviously activision being another part
of that so it's great to hear a lot of
this isn't just the logo a lot of it
isn't just kind of the reputation a
brand might have on instagram a lot of
it is really just staying close to the
community the culture you're trying to
get to
so let's let's talk a little bit about
tick tock and how tick-tock came to the
nfl right i mean it feels obvious but
the nfl's been cutting deals with every
other major social platform for a long
time so it feels like maybe there was a
moment early on where there was a little
bit of a bet that you you you took on
yourself and the organization to say we
have to invest into tick-tock tell us a
little bit about that moment because i
feel many brands are on the precipice of
coming in but you feel a little bit of
risk and a little bit of concern
and your experience might be able to
help them over the edge
sure yeah so
when i started at the nfl there were
three
big observations that i had the first
one was that there was an opportunity to
broaden the storytelling beyond the
field with players and to do that social
was going to play a key role in that
right you know independent of platform
you we really needed to to leverage that
and understand ways that we could
supercharge that
uh the second one was that we needed to
rebuild a structure internally that
could scale
internally we didn't have a structure
that could take on a tick tock
effectively or take on you know some of
these new emerging platforms really well
and the third was building direct
relationships with influencers that were
more social influencers so think phase
clan versus bradley cooper right and we
were much more i was much more
interested
in and going after the phase plan than
this going after bradley cooper because
we could drive always on engagement now
where were those people spending most of
their time uh increasingly it was you
know platforms like instagram platforms
like twitter and then obviously tick
tock emerged in 2019 so we wanted to be
on that platform before it really
reached a huge scale and we were
basically losing out on that audience
and so 2019 we launched uh pretty
quietly i would say we were testing some
things
and quickly we found out that the game
highlights were not really what was
driving the platform it was all this
ancillary content off the field the the
humor-based content the content that was
really focused on storytelling through
personality that was resonating to the
top so that we we really leaned into it
that way and i give my team you know
great amount of credit we have
functional experts that are on the
platform every day and understand it
very intimately and that's i think super
super important
yeah i think one of the things i've
observed is is how nitty gritty you
folks are in the comments
and a brand like the nfl engaging with
an individual that that might have no
followers on the platform
is what has allowed you to find those
opportunities to get close to culture
let's talk a little bit about culture
um and how you think about creators and
finding creators that allow you to speak
authentically to the community yeah
yeah let's get into that and of course i
want to bring up bring on emily z after
that yeah
yeah absolutely
for us i mean our influencer program and
what we do on the platform is is really
designed to build direct relationships
and how can we benefit the creator or
the influencer in a way that we're using
our brand scale the league scale to help
build their brands right and how can we
do that in ways that are accreted for
both right them bringing new audiences
to us and vice versa right we bring a
ton of
scale and opportunities with access and
so on around our games or otherwise that
could be really interesting to them for
great content opportunities
so as we do that uh tick tock is
obviously very interesting i think it's
it's fantastic we're all these amazing
creators and we're going to talk to one
here in a minute uh they're emerging and
they're merging very quickly so just
having your finger on the pulse of that
uh is super important we i've got an
amazing team again that that does that
and identifies who these creators are
we keep an eye on them and we see how
they're posting we want to make sure
that they're staying in a lane that's
positive that we're not going after
anything negative or tearing down you
know any teams or individuals and then
once we have a level of comfort you know
the team will come up with ideas on ways
that we can engage them and obviously
emily's a great example but but one of
many that we've been working with over
this past year we're going to continue
to scale that up
yeah i mean to that end let's actually
let's bring emily on
hi guys
hey
how are you
good how are you
amazing amazing i'm i'm expecting the uh
the comments to go pretty nuts right now
but why don't we just do a quick intro
um you can give a quick 30 second intro
not that you necessarily need one but
it'd be helpful context for this crew
because you're so multi-dimensional and
then i want to jump to a sizzle reel
that actually talks about the
partnership you and the nfl you and ian
have effectively put together which i
think is one of the best we've seen
um so please go
that's crazy yeah thank you so much for
having me um my name is emily zuge um i
make ugly logos on tick
they're beautiful
i mean beautiful beautiful sorry
um i started on tik-tok last year i'm
just kind of goofing around
i found some success with satire content
my first satire video i ever made made
barstool sports so that was like oh
there's some potential here and then
um in september the logo thing blew up
and now i'm on
this beautiful show
so
check out the linkedin page you can see
how she blessed us with this piece of
work that we may or may not convert into
an nft call it again
um but we won't talk about that
but you folks have done in a pretty a
pretty incredible and very organic
partnership and i think it speaks to a
lot of what ian discussed earlier around
structure infrastructure and being close
to culture and of course you just doing
what you do
so let's play let's play this quick
video for the audience and then i think
it'll set up the follow-up combo we have
i graduated college with a degree in
design and recently redesigned some
logos that i thought needed help
after going through the comments a lot
of large brands reached out to me for a
new logo so i said yes it's a really bad
logo this is my redesign of adobe i
really think i blew it out of the park
like a waste of space to me so this is
your new logo
nicole reached out to me they do sports
like football and such so i redesigned
it in a much more patriotic way i'm
pretty sure he is the president of the
football in america
thanks to emily we now have this
beautiful new logo for the niffle and
because we are the nipple we also wanted
to lend our resources
to emily just like emily i have a
passion for graphic design and i thought
her profile picture could use some
spicing up so i did some digging and
thought this best represents you and
also a name tag because it's not good
with names
[Music]
next i did detroit's football team the
lines
and i don't really understand your logo
so i just cleaned it up and this will
look a lot nicer on jerseys helmets
merchandise
what are lying in
they don't even say lions
try it
[Music]
that's so good
so um if we can like what made this
partnership so valuable in my mind is
how authentic it was it was clearly
you're getting hit up by brands all the
time
what was it about the nfl that stood out
what was it about how ian's team was
connecting with you
um if it was something else what was it
that made you gravitate towards it and
then ian would love to put your your
thoughts on just giving freedom and
letting emily do her thing you know nfl
is such a heritage brand and just being
free and letting the creator do her
thing here i think is a really important
takeaway sure
i think it was um
sort of when all this was blowing up i
wanted to sort of test the limits
and see how big of a response we could
get with it so the nfl is like everybody
knows the nfl you know what i mean um
so
i just threw them in there i thought hey
why not and i think people responded in
such a positive way because they met me
where i was at um
with the type of content that i make
even my like personality the delivery
was just so fantastic um i loved your
video
and um i think people responded in such
a positive way because we built this
fantastic relationship
off of like a joke
um
i think people just responded in such a
positive way and loved to see the nfl
just
collabing with some random tick-tocker
and being able to sort of um you know
poke fun at their own brand
yeah and i think that's a great a great
point emily and
peter
i think
looking at at tick tock
understanding that there's a
self-mocking nature to it creativity and
humor are at the center so if you're
gonna play on the platform you have to
be ready to embrace that so that that is
really central to having a great team uh
a big shout out to shannon and kylie and
josh and team for putting it together
and and they came to me with it and we
decided hey what's the what's the worst
worst that can happen here and
ultimately this was not going to kill
the nfl if it didn't go well i it was it
was worth the the risk if you want to
call it that and i think that's really
as a brand you have to do that analysis
for yourself is that something that
you're going to embrace a level of risk
uh and then really take the tone uh that
is on on tick-tock especially humor
self-mocking nature creativity and if
you're not going to do that i'd really
question what you're what you're going
to do
especially with creators like emily
because we wanted to share a bit of a
sandbox for her to create and then
obviously come back at her in a playful
way that was also in her
style so a couple takeaways
let the creator have his or her freedom
don't take your brand too seriously and
kind of live into the culture um so
really really valuable all right and we
have about you know six minutes or so
and i want to spend a little bit of time
talking about you
uh and some of your work um and one of
the things that stands out is this idea
of episodic content which we believe
that painters are such an important
thing we think 2022 is going to be a
really big year of long form not long
form short long form etc but branded
content in this episodic type of way
can you talk a little bit around your
thinking and the approach to the logo
design was it one of many ideas how did
that go and it start did it immediately
explode or did it require
a lot of commitment to it um
to really kind of build that out
yeah um so i think i i experimented with
episodic content really early on in my
tick tock career
um so
sort of how i mentioned before how my my
satire videos would they would do pretty
well because um
i would play this almost dumb blonde
character
and people feed into it and i just
thought it was the funniest thing
and um
eventually though some of the comments
they were hurting my ego so i was like
okay there are some people who know this
is a joke some people don't think it's a
joke so how can i bring this to the next
level
and eventually
um this is what really grew my my
relationship with my audience too i
started to make these comment reading
videos where i would choose the best
comments just the funniest um and i saw
that people would want to come back for
those and and they loved it they wanted
to see the next one so
um the logo design was just
another idea i had of maybe some graphic
designers will see this and and be like
what is she doing that is not how you do
it
and um it
kind of
blew up right away i think
just the sheer number of brands that
were commenting on it i think that was
what made it crazy you know
i think alone the concept is pretty
funny but just the fact that so many
brands were behind it and were jumping
in you know and wanted to kind of be in
on the joke um the comment section was
just like
no man like it was a free-for-all it was
so fun though it was is great
i mean to the point around the fake
accent um i don't know how many folks
here know the ellen story but you should
give uh you should give everyone here a
little bit of that
yeah
so um
if you've ever seen my tick tocks you
know i don't smile i don't laugh
um i have a pretty dry sense of humor on
tick tock but
um my
whole concept behind that was to i went
to art school so i wanted to be the
person that like annoyed me in art
critiques
so i tried to channel that and um just
be that person everybody kind of looks
at is like are they serious so um
yeah in real life i i smile i laugh i i
have a personality and um when i got the
call for the allen show
there was an idea thrown out where they
said hey you should
be like your tick tock persona and i
didn't sleep for like three days after
that
because i think it works very well on
tick tock but to be in a space where i'm
speaking to somebody and i can't edit it
the way i want to you know i can't cut
it i was
freaking out um and eventually i got the
green light that i could just smile and
be myself so that
really calmed my nerves
yeah yeah as we you know as we think
about tick tock and we you know uh
earlier we've had we heard some of the
guests speak about the algorithm how the
algorithm is so different and
speak a little bit about that challenge
potentially as a creator because i know
even our creators and others that we
work with find that to be inconsistent
but any tips and advice around
how to deal with that as a creator
yeah um i think
you know at the end of the day you
really
can't get to
you can't get too married to one concept
because the way that
tick tock works and society works trends
come and go so i think you definitely
should enjoy any success that you do
have but don't be afraid to branch out
and try new things um
because
why not i
i don't know i mean
there's just so much potential on
on the app and there's so many things
that you could do with it so um
also i think branching out to different
forms of social media is really
important because the tick tock
algorithm can be great sometimes and
then other times it can be like what's
going on you know if you're trying to to
switch up your content and uh try a new
a new concept
um so i think branching out to other
forms of media is really important
you know it's a great point because tick
tock is now everywhere
yeah and so you know are there look are
you looking at other platforms whether
it's snap or ig reels
or youtube shorts um and where we where
we could potentially find you
yes all the above i'm doing my absolute
best to grow
anywhere that i can i'm going to start
streaming on twitch soon
and uploading to youtube also um
so
that's in the future
and i'm excited
and i'm thankful
uh for tick-tock to give me this
platform too
fantastic
yeah go ahead andrea thank you emily ian
and peter this was remarkable it's
really nice to hear the back and forth
and love
love all the work that you've done
thanks so much for joining us today
thank you
thank you see you soon
and thank you peter
and next up we welcome britney diamond
from vayner
can you believe her doc
oh my gosh well it's gonna get even
better in just a second because we've
got the cmo
of eos products who's gonna be joining
you can you believe it brit how often do
we talk about her and all the work that
we do her ears must be ringing i think
they are okay so let's bring her on her
name is so young kang
um i have to share one i i love so young
you can tell she loves to take risks but
there's a story that she shared with us
that i think is a must tell because i
think it's something that she embraces
in her day-to-day work life as well
so while so young was on a backpack trip
and she was piranha fishing in the
amazon river she happened to fall into
the water so i think that says something
right there about how she goes about her
life so i'm going to now depart from
this conversation and let you guys take
it from here
i love it
i'm so excited for this you have no idea
um andrea already said it but we talk
about you
weekly if not many times a week um we've
been following you ever since the
you know the interaction that you had
with carly which we'll go over in a
little um but eos is just so great on
tick tock stalk them follow them um love
it all so
can't wait for everyone to get little
nuggets of wisdom from you i'm super
excited to be here thank you
of course so i guess we can start with
um you know what's your overall
philosophy on social as a whole
oh yeah i mean well social is hugely
important for us as a brand um
you probably already know but most of
our consumers are relatively young so we
really um just sort of like live and
breathe social across multiple platforms
and we do consider it our superpower we
focus a lot on it we are constantly
engaging with folks we learn a lot on it
we listen and we try to learn things
that are going to drive our business and
drive our brand
i love that and organizationally would
just love to know what were you brought
on to eos to do and what was really your
mission when you joined
yeah so i joined eos about three and a
half years ago um i'm the first ever
chief marketing officer for this
business it's existed for a little over
a decade um but they really brought me
in to
um see the brand into the next phase of
growth i mean the first like 10 years
were amazing in terms of growth through
largely this like super famous lip balm
that the brand is known for and then um
really the um the leadership wanted to
bring someone in to kind of say hey how
do we expand how do we stand for
something more than this famous product
that we that people are obsessed with
and that's really been my mandate and i
think we're you know we're talking about
tick tock and a lot of that has happened
on tick tock so tick tock has been very
good for growing our brand and
diversifying beyond what we used to
stand for
i was just gonna say so um would love
for you to give a little little overview
about what you're doing on tick-tock and
really how you started there i mean it
sounds like you were you were out to get
it from the get-go um so once it came up
it's no it's no surprise that you were
there
um and yeah yeah so i mean i think it's
really interesting because i've been
listening to all the sessions and i
think it's interesting that everyone
who's spoken so far has talked about the
fact that they've been on tick tock
since pretty early on for brands you
know we're sitting here and i'm sure
there are a lot of marketers right now
who are wondering when it's time to jump
in and i say like there's no time like
the present so we started looking at
tick tock like many other many of the
other speakers back in 2018
and we first started to um really market
on tick tock build a presence deliver
organic content build our own community
in 2019 as well i myself have been like
pretty active on tick tock not not as a
creator but like as a user as a consumer
of tick tock since 2018 as well and so
for us you know i i really do think that
like the brands that have taken the that
leap of faith into platforms that they
believe could be really integral to
their to their brand and reaching their
consumer
i think just like getting in it and
doing it and taking some risks and
jumping in even if you don't know
exactly what you're doing yet there's no
there's no better way to learn and then
ultimately like hone your game
um i will say you know we work with a
lot of brands and also um just overall
when something new comes along it's
scary right like tic tac is scary um
what was it like were there any barriers
in getting on the platform because it
was so new and it was so
different and you know brands are acting
different on tick tock than they are on
instagram facebook twitter um
what do you go through
well i mean we've always been a pretty
big we've always had a big social
following we have like millions of
followers across facebook and instagram
but the thing is is you know every
platform is different and then your
approach really needs to
to be different and you need to tailor
your content depending on like the
nuances of that platform the audience
the algorithm all of the above but
there's really no better way to refine
your strategy than to do it and to learn
and so for us um yeah there were a lot
of things that were maybe a little bit
bumpy in the initial phases um at the
time we were doing a lot we were
actually doing a lot directly with the
tick tock team like they helped us
license music they helped us like
discover creators um so there were
things that you know if i think back to
our our first activation versus like our
more you know recent um
uh marketing efforts on tick tock it has
changed a lot dramatically but we've
changed a lot too we've learned so much
in the course of that like almost three
years where we i think have learned what
works for us
we've tried a lot of things every time
we we run a campaign and we do something
new we basically set up um something
different so that we can try something
new that we've never done before whether
it's like the concept whether it's the
type of creator that we work with
whether it's like even just like the mix
between the organic versus the paid so
we're always mixing things up always
trying to learn new things and as a
result i feel like we packed in like so
much learning in what's actually been a
relatively short period of time
always be learning yeah if you get if
you can take anything away everyone
always be learning and always be testing
um from that would you say that your
voice or even your content has differed
on tick tock than it is on uh let's say
instagram
100 i mean 100 like so we um you know we
we talk about i think a lot of the folks
have who have spoken have talked about
the fact that like you can't take
yourself too seriously on tick tock
people can sniff out in authenticity
like from a mile away and so
being authentic being real being um
goofy one of one of my team members
actually recently said to me as we were
like hindsighting our annual performance
she was like you know as a brand we're
not afraid to get weird and she meant
that was the hugest compliment and i
think nothing exemplifies that more than
our tick tock content strategy we're not
afraid to get weird we're not afraid to
get real
we're not afraid to use the language and
like that that people use in their day
to day because on tick tock more than i
would say on any other platform that
we've ever engaged on we're part of the
community we're not just a brand talking
at people yeah and i would say and emily
alluded to it but the comment section is
just gold gold alerts in the comment
section so you're either gonna get a lot
of haters um if you're inauthentic or
you're gonna get a lot a lot of lovin
completely i completely agree with that
i love it all right before we even show
um you know carly's video i would love
for you to give three to five traits
that other companies can embody to you
know move at the speed of culture and
really do how much you've done in such a
short amount of time
i think that um
i think that the the appetite for risk
has to be there so being brave and and
feeling comfortable leaning in i think
has to be there i think that starts at
the leadership level but it has to
really be at the working team level as
well
and so so
you know bravery i think is one thing
but the only way that you can really
help your team and your organization be
brave is if you
um create a
an environment where it's okay for
people to learn and sometimes succeed
and sometimes fail and so that level of
like that learning mindset has to be
there and then the last piece is you
know in order to have that learning
mindset you really have to create a
sense of trust trust within your team
trust that if like i said like something
doesn't work that it's really a learning
opportunity versus a um you know a mark
against them so those are really the
kind of the hallmarks i think of of any
really great team that learns a lot and
learns fast and grows
i love it well before we bring on carly
would love to show the video um that
really jump started one of the most
amazing interactions i have
seen on tick tock um i i blush a little
every time i watch it so everyone
watching you might too um you're not
alone i can't wait
for my um
my people with
female parts out there i'm about to tell
you the secret for how to bless your
[ __ ] cooch
you need this [ __ ] it is an absolute
blessing and it you can dry shave with
this that's [ __ ] saying something i
use the fat ass venus gillette razors i
obviously cannot show my couch on camera
so pretend this is it right you're gonna
take this
hopefully in the shower if you're not
[ __ ] it it still works you're gonna put
that all there
then
listen to this [ __ ] part you're gonna
go down first then you're gonna go
sideways on half of it this way sideways
on halfway this way and then
you go up
i swear i swear by it whatever you
[ __ ] do do not use this [ __ ] it'll
make you smell like [ __ ] after a couple
days because it throws off your ph
balance don't [ __ ] do it and now you
have a smooth ass hoo-ha you're welcome
i love it carly i love it so much every
time i watch it it literally never gets
old
every time i see it i'm like oh my god i
really said that
it's amazing
oh my goodness and you know
i need to know
you put out a tick tock like that it's
the new demo i'm calling it the modern
demo right uh it's no longer boring it's
no longer a brand talking at you but
it's a a real person giving them their
real review
um but how surprised were you or were
you surprised that this blew up as big
as it did
well okay so at first um i wasn't as big
of a content creator back then but you
know i still had videos that like
probably every like once a month a video
would get a couple million likes but so
at first i was like
oh you know it's normal like i'm cussing
and being funny whatever
and then i just kept going
and it just kept going and going going
and i was like oh my god like wait hold
on so
yeah after a little bit i was like i
can't believe people want to listen to
me talk about shaving your
you know like that much but yeah it was
cool it was surprising
that's amazing um i have to say it came
up on my for you page so
um i'm i'm the demo right
i love it i need to know um well for
everyone here that was obviously an
original video from carly um but what
did eos do after this tick tock blew up
carly how did they respond and were you
did that even take you to a level two of
like wow this is has gone
way too far and now it's really up on a
mountain
so normally um i don't do sponsorships
or partnerships with brands or anything
because i think that like you said
they're inauthentic and i don't like not
being able to be myself on camera
but when they sent me well i actually
have one here when they sent me the
personalized bottles this says am i
allowed to cuss yeah go get them all
right
this says
bless your [ __ ] cooch on the front
um you need this [ __ ] you can dry shave
with it that's [ __ ] saying something
and the back is all the original
instructions and i really wasn't even
like considering the partnership until i
saw that
and then i was like oh my god like
holy crap and then yeah though that's
definitely the only reason i like went
with it because i realized like this
brand is willing to like let me just be
myself oh my god i can't even tell you
brittany like we were desperate to get
in touch with carly joy like desperate
so basically we did all of this within
like days like we created all custom
rebranded repackaged bottles with all
her words on it it was like the
thirstiest move that a brand has ever
like like attempted and we were
basically like trying to get her
attention that's literally the reason
why we did it we do edit her video
and that's when she replied to us and
and reached back out to us and then we
were able to collaborate together and it
was so authentic on her side and that's
what i like love about i mean like
she is so herself and that's what peop
that was that's what really resonated
with people and the fact that we could
then celebrate her authenticity and her
amazing like actual educational advice
on how to you know bless your cooch like
that's that was something that was such
a huge
golden opportunity for us but it was it
was totally a desperate move for us that
that's where this all originated from
well i just love that you used her words
right um and also totally leaned into
carly like you said the cursing just
like the whole whole thing um it was so
authentic on both both of your parts
right and i think that um that
the fact that you made that so quickly
um products take how long to get on
shelves and you were able to turn that
out
so quick is just
so so awesome and really shows how how
fast your organization really moves um
but i need to know uh
what were the results from this i
i've i know
there there probably is a little bit of
a perception problem of like there it's
only a lip balm which you alluded to a
little bit earlier but now um it's being
seen as this amazing uh shaving cream
what did this do for eos and what were
the results even in sales for it yeah so
we literally coming out of um this this
collaboration with carly joy we
basically doubled our our shave business
sales um
now that it's like a blessing and a
curse because we we doubled our sales
and then we actually ran out of product
we were sold out on shelves everywhere
like if you if you look at like tick
tocks and twitter commentary people are
like i'm desperate to [ __ ] to bless my
cooch but i cannot find the shave cream
anywhere so there's look for
unbelievable our business continues to
be up um you know continuing to arrive
at momentum so for anybody who is
doubtful
about what how whether tick tock can
influence and impact your sales i mean
this absolutely proves that with the
right partnership with the right creator
with the right authenticity it can
really move the needle on your business
and i
this blows me away because it didn't
come from content straight from your
brand it was complete community
management and like keeping your finger
on the pulse seeing what people are
saying about you um i like to say that
community management is the most
important thing that you can do um
especially on tick tock and this is
obviously a case of that yeah absolutely
i mean we actually we saw you carly
joy's content like right away she
actually i don't even know if you tagged
us on it carly like i think it just like
came across our for you pages
and then we were trying to reach out to
her because we were just like you know
like in love with with what she was
doing and um our response was really our
way for her to grab her attention um you
know because we had no other way to get
in touch with her
so yeah absolutely the insights come
through building a community building an
authentic community to always having
your ear to the ground and listening to
what's happening on the platform and
then if if you're if you're really fast
and you lean in you can really take
advantage of it as a marketer and turn
take that moment and turn it into
momentum for your business
nice um i know we only have one more
minute left but uh one more question for
you and that is
beyond just tick-tock beyond the um like
what you're doing on that platform
did carly's content um help you do any
other
tactics um in marketing for the actual
shave cream
i mean yeah so we actually we launched
this on our website like we had an
entire like d2c campaign that went on
around this um so this was like living
across all of our platforms um not just
on tick tock and then really it opened
up this dialogue because the thing that
i think
i really have to give carly joy huge
credit for
the way that she's taking a topic that
people are curious about and they want
to be educated on and like just being
real about it and that's what was like
beautiful about like the content is like
yeah like i want to know how to shave my
couch like nobody taught me that like so
harley joyce is going to teach me that
on tick tock um and and so like for us
that's that's also enabled just for our
brand to embrace a more open real and
authentic approach to education with our
consumers more broadly and so even
subsequently we've had like additional
content that we've launched along other
in other campaigns where we're just like
it's like real talk and it's solving
real problems for people but not in like
that sort of like hesitant corporate
speak but in like in real people's words
and that's what i really loved about um
carly joyce's content it's actually made
an impact an impact on our brand
yeah i mean i could only imagine also
google just how many people were
googling blessed by pooch you know
yes
it was the number it was the number one
search term on our site for quite some
time couch cream on our site everybody
was searching for couch cream some
people were searching for couch cream
just a little bit of a typo
i love it well thank you both so so much
for joining um this was amazing and
i mean i'm gonna be talking about you
every week so if your ears are ringing
you know why
we so love this is so great
thanks to you both for joining
excellent we're gonna welcome peter chun
back to the virtual stage and we have a
special guest peter guess who's coming
back
i cannot i cannot wait jameson the chief
tick-tock officer
of nerf
sophie we're so excited to have you we
want to hear all about what's been going
on since the last time we had a chance
to talk to you so i'm going to let you
guys dive right into it
amazing thank you thank you sophie
welcome
back um
i know you've got so much going on in
every good way so you've got to give a
little bit of that tea and gosh to this
audience
but for those that may not be familiar
with you you are the first you were and
i still think you still are the only
chief tick-tock officer that exists
which actually speaks to
how slow the market is moving into kind
of the space but tell us a little bit
around your role just do like the quick
30 second for those that are not aware
and a little bit of the origin story
that got you there which is which is
which is which actually speaks volumes
to hasbro as an organization nerf as a
brand believing in in in the platform in
the community
yeah i'll keep it short but uh just had
my own tick tock channel just posting
what i enjoyed you know i was excited to
get 10 followers didn't really care
about that was just creating content
that i liked
then kind of blew up nerf created this
position chief tick tock officer it was
super unique to apply you had to make a
tick tock video so i applied of course
and then got the job it was supposed to
be a max temporary gig for three months
and we're now on month nine with no end
in sight so
and and it's been
almost what five months since we last
had you on this to kind of talk about
you and and and some of the stuff you're
working on in the world of tick tock
that's an eternity
um so what's been going on what's been
keeping you busy and how things have
evolved and what's changed
even within the organization and how you
think about the platform
yeah absolutely so personally i've just
been given so much more responsibility
on the nerf team which is fantastic um
i'm actually like posting the content
now before i was just creating it and
then sending it through
now i'm logging in a tick tock posting
it and i'm creating videos months in
advance of course there's times when you
gotta move at the speed of culture so
you gotta change the scheduling around
and post a trend that day but otherwise
you know our calendar is nicely extended
still posting on my channel just keeping
up with trends and i've just learned so
much about so many things over the past
nine months has just been incredible
yeah the last time you were on there
were three things you really really
blessed the audience with one which is
25 of tick-tocks you produced were
actually successful
two you had
anywhere between three to five people
full time working within comments
and then the third thing was that you
know the company was still very hurt
naturally right when there was negative
commenting on the platform and that was
like a little bit of tension
are those three things still holding up
how has that evolved
let's add to the list and provide a
little bit more more fuel for those that
are that are watching and leaning in
absolutely yeah so a couple more pieces
of information that i've really seen
work successfully is
being the face of this brand has just
been integral
to getting people to watch the videos
you get one or two seconds when people
are scrolling through their for you page
so if they see me
this is not to sound hubris but if they
see me they know nerf so they're like oh
it's sophie lightning it's a nerf video
i'm gonna watch it so you get this
immediate hook and context that you
don't get if you're having a random
creator every day you know doing a
separate video people already have a
little bit of keyed in information as to
what's happening
i've also really been paying attention
to average watch time i think that
that's crucial
and most importantly just not getting
stuck up on follower and view count i've
really hit this point where just looking
at analytics and sales and roi
it's so much more important to have a
hundred people who
love what you're doing and watch every
tick tock and and are passionate versus
a million really passive viewers who are
just you know kind of along for the ride
so changing what we're valuing as a
company when we're analyzing the channel
has been so integral
so relevancy overreach
and really focusing on that you know
it's funny we talked a little bit with
emily zuge about episodic content and
obviously part of that is her being the
spokesperson
we've seen a lot of push into the mascot
space
um you know with with a lot of different
companies um you might have a hot take
on that but what are you oh yeah i got
hot takes this time last time i was a
little shy no
we're family let's go
no a mascot can be great it does like
kind of key in viewers to what's
happening but there is you know one
channel i think we all know it that is
doing phenomenal things with their
mascot and i see 15 to 30 carbon copies
of that that's just not going to work uh
when you're looking at literally
anything what matters is your channel
and what your viewers want to see so if
you're just copying somebody else it's
not gonna work so you can have a mascot
but the scandalous mascot is already
kind of taken you know so moving away
from that having having someone be the
face of the brand can be great it can be
a mascot somebody that viewers can
connect with you've got to make sure
that your mascot has its own individual
personality
so how would so what's some advice to to
help brands think through that because
it's easy to jump to a mascot they think
about it through the lens of their brand
they think about it in the lens of how
it makes their brand better they're not
necessarily thinking about how the brand
can connect with the community that's
always a second thought which which i
which we see as most marketers mistake
coming into the platform is they
introduce what they think their brand
should be versus
connecting with how the community's
speaking with the brand um but if a
brand is going down the mascot route
like what are what are some some things
to avoid and perhaps a couple things
that that they should lean into
i mean definitely just listening to your
community is so so crucial here reading
the comments and creating a personality
for this mascot that your viewers want
to see
and once again not copying like i just
think that that's so so important you
know and i just have any company will be
named will not be named yet but yeah
yeah no i'm not calling anybody out but
uh
got it got it um so let's talk a little
bit about
some of the trends that are different
today
than
than even 90 days ago or when you were
last on i mean there's so much that's
happening to the platform the platform
is more or less doubled
um what are you seeing yeah
yeah all right more hot takes um
i see a lot of brands building their
entire tick tock personality around
trends although it is
crucial to implement trends occasionally
you got to really hand select them and
create them only when they truly fit
into your content and your channel if
you build your whole image around trends
everybody does trends why do i want to
follow another channel that just does
trends it's the same exact thing why do
i want to follow your channel if you're
just posting ads if you're just
reposting videos from other social media
channels you know so it's just that type
of thing of diversifying and trends can
be so so powerful if you do them
correctly so you just have to understand
how your brand and how your niche fits
into the trend and really think about it
before you want to do it and keeping an
eye on that time if you're late to the
trend
you're late and you just got to accept
it and move on and find the next trend
if you're early you got to take the risk
if you think it's going to get big do it
before it gets big it's so much better
to do that flop than doing it late and
flopping you know at least you tried
yeah yeah there's a hindsight's always
20 20. but yeah we we talk a lot about
brands that want to jump into a trend
that may even be two or three weeks old
and it actually just shows you how slow
and how not contemporary the brands
actually are actually impressive
like you're you're in the corporate seat
right so in the brands my two to three
weeks is speed
but at the speed of culture it's late
and i think that's that's something that
i think a lot of brands get caught up
with let's let's talk a little bit about
creators because you were a creator then
you went brandside
talk a little bit about how you work
with creators today
and how that conversation starts to move
but also you know we are at the
precipice of the creator economy right
like instagram is gonna deploy majority
of their billion dollars that they
committed to the creator fund this year
youtube tick tock snap everyone 100
million dollars
as creators start to become more
integrated with corporate as they become
more integrated with creative
organizations within some of these
agencies and companies because of just
the endemic nature of what they do and
they can speak to the consumer
how should they be thinking about that
transition potentially and any other
words of advice
as as those as those creators want to
make the leap
definitely so you know for me i'm still
a creator at heart and although i'm
working on the corporate side i sold my
own channel but i also still am just a
creator for the brand and nerf had this
monumental decision to make we had
people apply for this position cto that
had 10 times as many followers as me so
they had to go and choose between the
authentic person who is known for nerf
or the person with the following and i
think that's already been kind of
covered throughout previous guests
earlier today but just picking the
creator that is authentic and actually
enjoys the brand you can tell it's it's
so silly you can tell when the creator
isn't enjoying what they're doing you
have to give them trust you gotta you
can't keep them on a short leash you
can't tell them what they should produce
uh
i feel like creating an actual
influential video on tick tock is all
about being actually passionate about
what you're talking about so somebody
came to me right now with a script for a
tick tock video and was like i'll pay
you a million dollars i would say no i'm
not doing that i would hate it it would
not represent who i am and i think a lot
of other creators agree with that as
well as just overall success rate it's
just not to be as successful
sophie thanks so much for taking time
joining us again we're going to have you
on again in five months to bless us with
more insight on trends
incredible let's lock her in now yes
let's do it before she gets even bigger
that's right so
thanks guys
fantastic
next we will welcome ryan harwood to the
virtual stage ryan how are you doing
how's it going oh good i'm excited
you're going to take us home the final
lap of marketing for the now where we're
going to hear from a whole slew of
exciting creators
so thank you for that and first up we've
got spencer x
he's a beat boxer director and internet
personality
he is one of the largest original sound
creators on tik tok with over a thousand
original sounds billions of views and
over 50 million followers and i happen
to say i love your life motto
persistence patience and possibility
welcome thank you thank you so much
thank you guys for having me here uh i
love it spencer what's up my man
oh man living the life of a beat boxer
man
in los angeles now missing missing my
home in new york city
new york city misses you as well
well thanks for joining us today i
appreciate your time you know before i
jump into
the world of tick tock with you you know
you've been a creator for a long time
tell me what was the first
platform that you started creating
content on before i shift gears to
tick-tock space yeah what a loaded
question man uh that that's yeah i've
been doing beatboxing since
like
15 years now so uh first time i created
content was on youtube i want to say it
was like in 2000
and i have actually a previous youtube
that i've had before the youtube that
you see right now
uh because that one was created in 2012
when i was in an acapella group
um
but uh i started like in 2008 man dude
that like back in like 2008 2009
um and that was the first time i i found
out about the internet really like it
was like not actually but it was the
first time i used the internet as a
resource to
widen my perspective about the world um
totally and yeah yeah that's that you
just threw me back right now
and when tick-tock came on your radar
were you
fast to move over to that platform or
were you hesitant at first and then kind
of slowly adopted it and then realized
it's all about music and it's perfect
for someone like you like how did you
think about that
that's a really that's another
interesting question because i didn't
see myself as
much of a content creator back then i
thought i was like hey all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna get into the space i'm
just gonna make some videos someone's
going to recognize me i'm a beatboxer
i'm very very unique but never did i
think like wow this is going to turn
into something that was
you know
top 10 in america
1 000 unique sounds billions of views uh
no uh my plan was to put out a a song a
day a beat a day
um and uh man it didn't take me a lot of
convincing it took because a lot of
people told me about musically a lot of
people told me about musically and i was
like
musically musically has been around for
a while and once they had the brand
changed to tick-tock um at this point i
was like at like year three or four
listening to gary
um
and you know he he knows this well now
but uh back then man i was dying to tell
him he was the reason for why i got on
tick-tock
um i it was you know it just made sense
uh
every artist he was speaking to every
conversation he had revolved around this
new platform and i was like
what's going on right now
it was february of 2019
and i took a look at it and
the first thing that i realized was wow
this is the most direct social media has
ever been this is the most transparent
that we've ever had with a screen in
front of us um and i really really felt
like i was you know living the lives of
these people that were dancing in their
living rooms and in in their you know
bathrooms or in their kitchens and so
yeah it didn't take a lot of convincing
for me once i figured out it was a
purple question yeah and how is the rise
of tick tock impacted your career
trajectory and like just goals as a
content creator
wow
man i i can't thank i can't thank uh
tick tock enough thank you tick tock
everybody that's happened
that supports me i love you i love you
so much you uh i mean it's changed my
life you know ever it's changed the way
that i've i've thought about many many
things from uh you know how to how to
communicate with my interpersonal
relationships team other how to treat
other people how to how to be in this
world how to communicate with my fans um
how i think about music itself how i
think about what music does
um you can go deeper into there i just
think it's like a frequency and light
thing right now and it's it's beautiful
it's really really really beautiful to
see how the world's come together
uh
with the power of uh of tick tock and
and social
um
man i i'm forever in in depth to
i'm i'm a happy camper okay that's
awesome
and and tell us how collaborating with
other creators contributes to your
creative process you know as someone
that creates beats your collaboration
possibilities are endless it's pretty
wild so how does that contribute to your
creative process man i i'm very
fortunate and i've said this for a while
to it's a double-edged sword to be a
beatboxer uh because on one hand i might
be the most interesting person in the
space and kind of like you know what is
going on who is that what is he doing
and on the other hand it's very very
easy for me to collaborate because i've
been doing this for
so so so so long um back on youtube i've
i've privated all those videos but i
used to have a series called the box
series and actually not a lot of people
know about this and if you do
wow because it's like 10 years old but i
used to have something called like
guitar box piano box electro box rat box
live poetry box all these things i used
to get myself into as many places as i
could
because i realized the potential beat
boxing was so much more than what it was
online yeah and uh i i've just been i've
been a collaborator for for for a while
when i got on tick tock what i realized
was everyone's collaborating with each
other i got to get in this space and i
got to make the right moves with the
right people um let me know let me get
to know the community um let me let me
figure out what uh what what they're
doing how are they doing it i saw
everyone was in los angeles at the time
i was uh going from ramen bowl to ramen
bowl here just to you know figure it out
and um i i set a goal and i don't know
what happened man but i counted it um
and in a month i had over 50
collaborations
and i was i just ran it was like three a
day or something and i just ran ran
uh and just figured it out um
and they got me to got me to think a lot
more it got me to to understand that
this world you know everyone wants to do
you know the best version of themselves
by themselves right
but you know it really is about the
people around you it really is about how
you connect with people too and how you
um
every time that you connect like this
right here this connection right here
we're we're exploring so many different
mediums that we wouldn't have if we
wouldn't have this conversation so this
is a collaboration right here it's a
beautiful collaboration right here and i
i think collaboration's the way that you
know the the world goes around we
wouldn't we'd just be stuck on one ideas
all the time if it wasn't
so this always ends way faster than i
wanted to and we're almost the time i
the whole entire comment section is
asking they they want to hear a beat so
you got to throw us a beat live i'm
putting you on the spot give us a 30
second beat go for it
just for ya
[Music]
new
that is sick that is incredible now i
know why they're putting you in netflix
movies left and right i love it i'm i'm
thankful man i'm thankful i'm grateful
and i'm i'm looking forward to what uh
what's coming
awesome i'm looking forward to hanging
in person thanks spencer
that was amazing i am dying over here i
am dying oh my god we have to get that
in our in there can we use that in our
opening video spencer absolutely i'm
gonna send you that check for a billion
dollars i'm gonna get gary right on that
i want to see garyvee i know gary can do
everything right okay that's right
that's right thank you so much for
joining us you guys have an amazing day
thank you all right you too
all right ryan we got another one for
you
michael lee
hello
dancer choreographer and social media
personality with how many followers 51
million
wow
thank you thank you
what's up michael how you doing i'm good
i'm good just uh woke up and like a few
hours ago um planning out my day getting
into the tons of meetings uh a lot of
back-end stuff honestly
good good good i love you on the west
coast okay yeah yeah
awesome well listen let's jump right
into it you know i love origin stories
tell me tell me in a nutshell how you
became a creator was it purposeful or
was it by accident oh man uh it was
crazy yeah so i started off in 2012 as a
dancer um going to sean's dance factory
um a hip-hop studio in florida um and
basically my whole life i was kind of
like always addicted to social media
youtube specifically and i was always in
love with like the main creators like uh
when youtube started it was like
ryan higa kev jumbo smosh like all of
those og youtubers and it kind of showed
me like yo these people are like making
livings out of doing
having fun making videos inspiring
people and it was so inspiring to me so
in 2015 specifically that's when i was
kind of like a little bit more into
you know dancing i was starting to
become a little more professional um
posting my own videos and in 2015 that's
when i like decided i was like all right
it's not a matter of how it's a matter
of when um i just got to go for it you
know like i learned that the main thing
that
differentiated
i guess the top creators from like
people who wanted to do it was like just
how much grind they really put into it
and um from there i was like all right i
mean like you know it no one's perfect
in this everyone has their own thing and
i think if i just keep going it's i'm
gonna figure it out and um
that's pretty much pretty much what i
did i became the first uh social media
like one of the first social media
dancers in the dance culture um you know
kind of pushed through that and then i
gained in that four years about like 250
000 followers on like all socials
and then once tick tock came back um
uh on in 2019 that's when they really
really pushed marketing
um i had about 600 000 on on musically
at the time so when i hopped back on
that first week
it was crazy uh my friends were on it
and they told me to hop on it like yo
like this is you know it's doing well i
was like all right let me check it out
first week i hit a million followers and
that was my first million on any social
and i was like whoa
and every week consistently after that i
was just like literally all of my focus
on every platform was erased and i just
focused on the tick tock and every week
i was gaining consistently another
million followers
and i was like this is crazy i started
telling you all my collaborations all of
my dance people everyone that was around
and i was like yo this is the next vine
because vine was like i missed out on
the vine opportunity so i was like i
can't i can't miss on this this is like
super important and just being on time
with something like
having this chance to be i guess you
know bigger than what you want to be
it is some it's a mix of like
consistency consistency and skill and
and you know hard work but the other
part is also like timing and
chance as well you know it was chance
that this just kind of worked and um and
and i pushed through and months later i
moved to la with like 15 20 mil and then
like a few months later i moved my
family out with me and then i just
started the whole family brand thing and
i haven't stopped ever since and now i'm
moving into the whole nft space and
getting into the whole web 3.0 gaming
space and and yeah that's that's my
whole nutshell
i love it i love it so what tick tock
taught you was be early go fast you're
doing it again with web 3.0 right now
with nft yeah
fantastic tell me how do you think about
when you create content for instagram
versus tick tock what's the mentality
there is there a shift in mentality how
do you think about the two platforms
differently
yeah i mean for instagram i'm honestly
still figuring out how i can really
manage my time with what makes the most
sense um i mean instagram it kind of
just looks like your portfolio
i'm i'm like a little like more picky
with how i want to create and like
show
and how i represent myself on instagram
so i'm i'm honestly kind of figuring out
okay like what what works for me because
everything works for different creators
um for me it's more of like a specific
style of dance videos and then um
pictures you know if i were to post tick
tocks on it which i do sometimes um it
doesn't do as well as i would expect so
so it's kind of like a shift in in like
all right what works because it's a
different audience and from there uh you
just have to kind of
tend to that specific audience based on
the platform
totally
you know when you work with with brands
how do you prefer that they engage with
you process wise do you prefer they lead
the creative direction
or not at all i prefer i mean for me i'm
i'm super creative so i i kind of know
like all right this is gonna work for me
this is not gonna work for me you know
like i can give you and i and i always
try to advise and try to like put in my
two cents like yo like you know this is
a good idea but i also think like if we
did it this way or we tweaked certain
things this could
feel more i guess
um natural to the viewer on tick tock
because a lot of companies that come
into tick tock they just think oh if we
put in a high production and do like
this crazy you know thing that should
look like it's on tv
it's gonna do amazing which you know and
then it doesn't really resonate because
they're not really speaking to their
target audience they're speaking to kids
they're speaking to these you know
teenagers or kids that are watching and
swiping through and then obviously they
see something that's completely
sticking out like a sore thumb is kind
of like
what is this you know so
i try to kind of find the balance of
like professional and natural yeah um
and yeah
makes sense
and you know obviously you do a lot of
dance videos that that was kind of the
rise of how yeah
following begin do you ever test new
styles or formats of content and if you
do
how do you determine if it's a direction
you should continue to go in knowing
that you know you gained your audience
from a very specific style of video yeah
think about that um i i definitely
experimented a lot in the beginning
uh in the beginning it was like the most
experimental i just i did whatever i
could and and you know sometimes it
usually worked out and mainly because i
was just like thinking of ideas that
other people didn't think of i guess if
that made sense it was a lot easier also
because the competition back then was
like you know way less
so that was another factor but
other than dance videos you know in my
room or in my house i started like okay
what can i do to elevate this like what
do i love to watch like what's ballsy
what's crazy i started going to walmart
dancing on counters dancing in
escalators you know like in in the mall
like that's that was the stuff that
really started popping me off and i
started making more skit like vibes with
the dancers so not only was the the
talent was was in the video it was also
the skit and the the story behind it
like oh this guy started dancing but not
only that he jumped in the car oh my
gosh the guy out in the front of the car
he ran out and tackled him you know like
so it was like this whole skit idea of
like making content
with just dancing content to basically
just bring it together
yeah
is that your um
son in the videos with you sometimes oh
no that's my little brother
okay yeah yeah i have uh i have two
little brothers and uh and a little
sister
yeah that he can dance as well huh yeah
i mean he actually he actually took a
pretty long hiatus he started just you
know playing a whole bunch of video
games and you know it was hard for me
because i didn't have time to teach him
anymore so recently i actually put him
now he's in
four times a week dance classes he has
five times a week tumbling classes like
like i'm really just kind of putting him
into a whole bunch of stuff to keep him
active and constantly growing and yeah
it's pretty cool
i love it we're gonna do a quick speed
round of questions to get to know
michael all right
disney plus or netflix
oh disney plus
summer or winter
80s or 90s music
90s
beach or mountains
beach
friends are seinfeld
friends
red wine or white wine
neither i don't like wine
there you go
kanye
oh
drake
and last one who is your favorite person
to follow on tick tock
oh hard one right for me uh i think it
would be uh it's king chris
all right all right michael thank you so
much for joining us today we really
appreciate your time of course
appreciate you guys michael
let's talk nft soon
yeah that's right sneaking it in all
right ryan we've got ellie zeeler up
next
ellie is a 17 year old content creator
with 10 and a half million followers on
tick tock nearly 2 million on instagram
and a growing youtube channel
i love ally that you combine all your
passions fashion beauty and lifestyle to
be able to create your content and
you've done it with some pretty cool
brands like lancome levi's amazon and a
whole lot more welcome welcome
thank you so much i love those
introductions it shocks me every time
when people say those things
how you doing ellie i'm doing well how
are you
good thank you for joining us today we
appreciate it thank you for having me
i'm so excited
yeah so you know similar to to when i
was just talking to michael i i really
do love origin stories and i want to
know in a nutshell like how did you
become a creator was it purposeful or
was it by accident
it was a little mix of both so i grew up
always loving film i was always in film
camps and in film classes and i loved
youtube and i would film and edit videos
in my free time
whenever i had free time and i would
never post them because i also was
in a very competitive school environment
and so i was an athlete and a straight a
student and i had a non-profit
organization and so i really did not
have time to sit down and get to be
creative but when quarantine hit like
for most people we all had
so much time and i finally got to really
dig in and find that creative side of
myself but it didn't initially start
like that so
i started really how i feel like a lot
of people know tick tock to be in the
past and in quarantine which were these
trending dance videos and so i really
started on there and i grew from that
pretty rapidly and then from there i
really wanted to show people who i was
and what i stood for and what i was
interested in and so i really knew that
my followers loved me for me and so for
example instead of just doing a dance
video in my sweats like a lot of us were
doing in quarantine i would switch in
some fashion and some makeup content and
as well as being funny and serious and
editing all things together so people
really got to know who i was
which is hopefully now
awesome awesome
you know i you have a lot of engagement
in your channel you you have a real
community which is amazing how do you
determine
how many comments you're going to
respond to on any given post any given
day how do you how do you make sure that
you're walking that thin line between
like engaging with the community and
not wasting all your entire days
responding to comments it's not only
like wasting my entire day but i could
be scrolling and then i'll see a hate
comment and it will just ruin the day as
well and so i really like to when i
first initially post i'll go through and
i'll really like to respond to comments
that have clearly watched the video and
are asking me a question or telling me
something about me something like that
and i love responding to those um
i really have not i really try not to
respond to hate comments in fact i
really never respond to hate comments
because i've really noticed that
um it's really this attention kind of
search for a lot of people and so
honestly something that i've seen in a
little life hack if you're getting hate
comments is when people do post
something or comment something nice and
you respond to those a lot of people
just want a response out of you and so
usually they go into the next videos and
start commenting some love but
it's really easy to respond to people
that you can tell put thought into these
comments and who really care and it's
really it's much easier to imagine a
person behind the screen so yeah
love it and
how has the rise of tick-tock impacted
your career trajectory and goals as a
content creator obviously you said
quarantine you kind of had more time on
your hands you started creating so this
wasn't necessarily something that like
was fully purposeful
yeah right no this was not in the plan
i'm again so happy that it turned out to
be like this but as i said before i
really grew up in this super competitive
environment in california and so i went
to a really competitive high school and
they taught us that if you didn't have a
4.5 and if you weren't the best athlete
on your team and had businesses and
non-profits that you wouldn't get into
college and ultimately if you go to
college you get a job you become
successful and that was just the
trajectory that i was put on to and that
i feel like a lot of teenagers and kids
in high school are put on to
and with that i really suppressed my
love of media and film and editing and
this just other whole creative side that
no one ever got to see
and so
um with quarantine and with everything
opening up i really got to
discover that creative side and this is
really
i think social media and doing things by
yourself instead of this trajectory
trajectory long-term plan that people
put you on
have really sped up the process for me
like i really felt like i was meant to
do these things but instead i'm getting
to achieve all of these incredible
things at 17 and 18 soon instead of
maybe 25 or in my 30s when everyone told
me i was going to
yeah it's funny i i also you know i came
out of school and it's a very similar
way where people tried to tell you the
right way to have success in life and
the right task
and finance was kind of where i was
brainwashed where you had to go and i
spent probably five to seven years of my
career in finance before before pivoting
to a completely different industry and
you kind of just need to know in your
gut when you need to go with it when
life puts you on a different path so
it's really 100 and i even
had the idea where i was like okay i'm
gonna grind it out and do these like
specific jobs that i've only been taught
and then maybe later in life when i'm
older i can get to do things that i'm
actually passionate about and so i'm so
grateful that every day i get to do
something that i genuinely really enjoy
and that people have taught me maybe in
the past that you couldn't be successful
with but now
everyone really has seen that there is a
way
there's a couple people in the comments
saying you hit a mean golf ball is that
true
i do try to hit a mean golf ball i mean
that was the sport that a lot of people
or that i tried on and so i was on
varsity golf and i grew up playing golf
my brothers and dads or dad um are
really into playing the sport and so
uh that was just another example of like
me starting on tick tock with trending
dances and then like a few months later
showing people what i really liked and
enjoyed which at the time was golf too
so thank you to whoever said that
and when you think of instagram vs tick
tock how do you think about creating
content differently for these two
platforms
it's very interesting because i think
that tick tock and youtube you really
get to show a different side of yourself
and you really get to have people engage
and have a real connection with you
um instagram i think is more of this
staged kind of platform that a lot of
people have
seen it as and so i like to kind of show
people that sensitive side of myself and
show people how to get and achieve maybe
a look or a makeup look or a fashion
something and then
get to
put that on
the instagram platform
yep
and
do you try to collaborate with other
large creators is that something that
you enjoy doing that's part of your
strategy in general of creating content
is it not something you think about how
does it contribute your creative process
learning from other creators all of that
i think it's interesting because i do
definitely and i think a lot of people
on tick tock do learn from other
creators obviously tick tock is really a
trending platform and so if you see
other people doing a trend then i'm sure
you're you will want to participate in
that trend uh it's very interesting
because i really have gotten to the
point where i am um doing all of this
from my parents house and i really have
not collaborated with a lot of people
again i would love to and i think that
you know i'm moving to la in a couple of
weeks and so i'm excited to kind of
start that journey but also it gives me
kind of this sense of all of these
people that i've gathered up and that
are following me are really following me
for myself and not for anyone else and
so i think it goes one of two ways but
also
super open to it and excited for that
next stage too
is there one creator that you'd love to
collab with that's someone that you're
just like i love their style i'd love to
collaborate with them i'm putting you on
the spot there a little bit oh that is
putting me on the spot i love it's so
interesting because i feel like with
doing so many different things versus
whether it's like cooking videos golf
videos fashion all these different
things i have a favorite creator i think
in each category the first one that
comes to mind are like the fashion
influencers that i love and so like
brittany xavier and this girl who's like
the rich mom where you go and i think it
would just be cool to like read their
closets and
make some content some videos
i love it all right speed round of
questions let's get to know ellie all
right okay here we go disney plus or
netflix
netflix
almond milk or oat milk almond milk
vanilla or chocolate
chocolate
twitter or instagram
instagram
what was your first cell phone
oh my gosh
like the the stage i had an iphone
yeah okay maybe like an iphone
i had like an ipod actually i've had
there we go
i don't know anyway an apple product
last one burger pizza
pizza
it's all the way
all right ellie thank you so much for
joining us today we really appreciate it
so great thank you ellie
thank you guys so much we'll see you
soon
all right we got the last one ryan
last but not least we're gonna welcome
the old gays
we've got robert and mick and bill and
jesse all right they're all for here
let's go we love that they're they're
navigating their golden years together
they've got 5.4 million followers on
social media 700 million
views we're already setting it straight
i'm going to let them introduce
themselves
away
welcome guys welcome thank you for
joining us today glad to be here thank
you i
i was very very excited for this
interview so i'm glad you're here and
and the first thing i need to know is
every obviously tick tock
everyone always labeled it the past
couple years is very much a gen z
platform it was a platform that was for
younger folks
how did you guys
start on tick tock who told you about
the platform why did you get on i need
to know the origin story
well it actually started with ryan our
producer and last december he had robert
do just some silly things with the santa
hat and coming into the door and all
that kind of stuff
and
that's how it started and then it just
from there it absolutely
went through the roof
and how do you guys know each other
what's the relationship over the years
we're
neighbors really yes
yes i live catty corner to mick and
robert and we call bill down the hill
bill
but we're just like
a minute's throw from each other
i love it were you on social media
platforms together before tick tock or
was tick tock the first time you came
together
first time okay great yeah no we were
well we were on youtube before we have
about 50 videos on youtube where we had
about 55 million likes
i love it all right and how do you guys
think about authentically engaging your
audience on a platform like tick tock
are you guys mining the comments in
order to see what the audience wants are
you trying to play to like the different
age groups on a platform like tik tok
how do you think about authentically
engaging them
we can't hear you mick and robert for
some reason though the audio
i i have to tell you we don't do any of
that
ryan does all that and what makes us
really authentic on tick tock is the
fact that
we when we go into a situation we don't
know what we're going into
all of a sudden ryan throws it at us and
we answer and our and authenticity has
really what makes us really
i think great oh yeah so you guys are
real performers and entertainers at the
truest form i love it
and and you know how has the rise of
tick tock impacted your career
trajectory how has it affected your
lives just in general
uh it's given us a lot of love
tons of it of hugs and it's just been uh
good
we've stretched from it these guys have
stretched me so much in to being myself
and not worrying about what the world i
mean not the world but but what people
think because
we're okay and we're loved and um they
realize that
um old gays aren't dead gays
absolutely have you had your moment yet
where you've walked in public and people
were like oh it's the old gays from
tick-tock
time
we
on our way to the drew barrimore show
last year
we went through six different airports
and we were recognized at every single
airport and at dallas fort worth they
were lining up to take selfies with us
and that
that was over the top i mean i i've
never had that kind of feeling before in
my life it was absolutely incredible
and even walking down the street also is
just it's just so fun to
to see people even you've got your mask
on and they still know who you are
yeah i i walked into trader joe's the
other day went to the checkout counter
uh to buy my stuff i had my mask on and
this checker said to me she said oh
how's your day and i said oh i said it's
going good she looked me said tick-tock
she just recognized me by my voice she
said you're my favorites
i love it i love it
mick robert is the volume working this
time or is it
i don't know can you hear us now
yeah
yeah
guys welcome guys
thank you
so so tell me is there you know as
you've now started to work with
different brands and brand partnerships
has there been a brand partnership that
stands out in your mind that just worked
very seamlessly because they gave you
certain creative freedom and it just you
enjoyed it a great deal is there one
that stands out for you guys
well paul roth uh i can't remember
working with that they're very gracious
and
sending us some wonderful stuff
i love it i love it
and
you know do you prefer brands to engage
with you by by you guys leading the
creative direction or do you like them
to kind of give you explicit direction
on what they think is going to work how
do you guys like to work with brands
from that perspective well i would say
it kind of depends sometimes it works
out and sometimes it doesn't and we have
to be creative uh i really you know we
defer to ryan
when it comes to that because he may
say he may look at you know material
that's coming in from what the uh the uh
client wants and instead
uh you know say we say well let's try
something different
you know we're always looking for
something that has a little bit of an
edge here and also that engages with um
you know our primary mark which are the
tick-tock viewers who are quite frankly
several generations younger than us
yeah i was going to say do you you
probably spans the gamut you guys are
probably one of the most from a
diversity perspective age groups
different demographics i'm sure you have
such a diverse demographic base that is
following you is that right
yeah yes yes
and brian graydon that's working with us
says that our appeal is we cut across
all demographics
yep that makes a lot of sense
um
all right let me uh jump into a speed
round of questions here guys i want to
uh i want to get to know the old gays a
little bit better so i'm going to first
go with the question if you could travel
back to blockbuster
what movie
and snack would you choose right now
the snack would be popcorn caramel
popcorn
my snack would be milk duds
buttered popcorn
and mick
red vines
a lot of different choices there
um summer or winter what do you guys
prefer
summer
winter
all right
50s 60s or 70s music
60s
60s
17
70s
vanilla or chocolate
chocolate chocolate
chocolate
friends are seinfeld
friends
friends
neither
and i want to know from each of you who
is the best music artist of all time
from your point of view
patti labelle is my love
whitney houston
i would say frank sinatra
and bill
tina turner
i love that
guys thank you so much for joining us
today i'm on marketingphone now we
really appreciate your time
that was incredible
thank you guys
oh that was so fun ryan
i i want you to keep asking questions or
you could have gone a lot i think you
could have kept that one going
thank you for having me on today all
right
we hope to see you in february all of
you please join us we've got our next
episode on the 17th of february from 12
to 1 pm
we're going to focus on the hot takes
for 2022 a mix of business speakers as
well as a couple of uh pretty famous
inspirational authors um and we can't
wait to continue the conversation
marketing for the now let us know what
you think uh we should have on some of
our future shows
and check out any past episodes on
mftn.vaynerx.com
we'd love to hear from you
see you soon